so you come home long day after your
rockstar in your ninja and you sit down
on your couch which of course I envision
looks something like this and you have a
little bit of spare time at the end of
the day and you decide what you're gonna
do with that spare time you're having a
moment and in that moment you have to
decide what am I gonna do what am I
gonna watch maybe something with
superheroes how about that new lawyer
show how about that show with superhero
lawyers maybe something a little
romantic perhaps a comedy number one
Bojack fan maybe romantic comedy how
about something grand and epic or
something epically spooky maybe a
political documentary I'm just kidding I
know having a prison documenter I was
funny twice how about an actual
documentary maybe something about
retirees powerful women powerful women
retirees in their natural habitat so you
make your decision whatever that might
be you're presented with the play button
you've made your choice you sit down
you're ready you hit play and this is
what you see never yeah this is a
fictitious nobody's ever actually seen
this before where a debuting it at the
conference today
now if you have had this unfortunate
experience I've long said we should
actually change this out for this that
way if we're having a bad day we're at
least help you make healthy life choices
so anyway you're presented with this and
you might say to yourself huh is it just
me so maybe decide I'll check Twitter
maybe Facebook or a couple of those news
sites so what's going on at Netflix so I
call this next bit a byte about Netflix
I used to call it a bit about Netflix
but this is at least eight times better
I love tech conferences because
everybody gets the nerd jokes and I have
this experiment so Netflix is a large
data and telemetry company that has the
byproduct of streaming video over the
Internet okay it was another joke it's
gonna be a couple more just ask that you
keep up with in 2016 Netflix went global
Netflix is now available in over 190
countries in the world - those few
little gray areas that just aren't quite
ready for our brand of entertainment
just yet when you talk to Netflix you
talk primarily to three different places
Netflix has a large infrastructure in
Amazon Web Services it's where we do all
of our compute and storage a little bit
with Akamai UI assets and small assets
to help build out that UI that you look
at and then Netflix open connect is our
purpose-built video CDN any video bits
that you see while viewing Netflix come
from our CDN
a few years ago when we first started
out we would stream from one of the big
three the lime lights the Akamai is the
level threes but over time we found some
problems first of all see the ends can
be a little expensive especially if you
have video files and a lot of them that
kind of big its be even a bit more
secondly they have requirements around
their their business processes and needs
and goals that Netflix doesn't have any
time they are to place a cash somewhere
whether it's you know in data center or
an IX or embedded in a network they have
to have some kind of profit model
associated with the placement of that
cash so unless you're on a very large
network if you're on a medium size
network or a smaller one they can't make
as much investment in the caching
infrastructure so that means we can't
put as much Netflix out there so we
started building our own because our
goals are to help win those moments of
truth that we were talking about earlier
and one of the best ways that I can do
that beyond amazing content amazing
content thank you thank you you're
following along very well and very much
is that you have a good experience so
with the Netflix open connect CDN we can
take our caching machines and approach
any ISP and give them a stack of caching
equipment for free and ask them to put
it inside of their network this provides
some really nice benefits really for
everybody involved you as someone who is
consuming Netflix those video bits are
now much more close to you and you don't
have to go through the drain point at
your ISPs network out to the Internet
there you know you're not worried about
some of those some of those choke points
that happen in those areas and typically
your communication is simpler in the
cleaner your ISP oftentimes has to pay
transit costs to talk to other networks
while spits stick feel like I'm doing
another kind of show they have to pay
those transit costs on the Internet and
you may have seen a few of those stories
to talk about how at least in the US
Netflix is Peaks out at about 37% of us
Internet bandwidth at peak time that
means that 37% of the transit kadjar
ISPs are paying for so that you can
watch any of those shows if we put those
caches inside of their network they get
all that transit cost back so reduces it
reduces cost for ISPs it makes the
experience better for our customers and
we win just the story behind the net
flicks open connect CDN it's another one
of our interesting open source projects
everything about the hardware and the
software and how we put it together is
available at open connect Netflix comm
if you're curious about how we chose to
run a CDN Netflix is a large
micro-services infrastructure it kind of
looks like this I'll give those of you
taking notes a minute it's a little bit
of a complex ever-changing beast I think
it's pretty safe to say at this point
Netflix is complex enough that there's
not one person inside the organization
that really understands all of it even
if we break it down to just one of the
other services and we look for instance
at call paths coming off of that service
it still kind of looks like this so
Netflix is made up of hundreds of micro
services there are thousands of daily
production changes and I don't mean you
know we updated a record in a database
your code pushes feature flag changes
things that actually change our
production environment thousands of
those we run tens of thousands of
virtual instances inside of Amazon we
have hundreds of customer hundreds of
thousands of customer interactions were
naturally activates every second now I
actually need to update my slide
hundreds of thousands of customer
interactions every second we have
millions of customers as of Tuesday when
we published those numbers that's now at
eighty one point five million global
Netflix customers billions of
time-series metrics currently we run
about two and a half billion time-series
metrics every minute that are delivered
processed and stored we've strained tens
of billions of hours of entertainment to
our customers every quarter we do this
with tens of operations engineers and no
knobs we also don't have anything that
is a knock and has cleverly been renamed
to something else so nobody calls it in
off we don't have data centers anymore
Netflix made that transition we started
make sure I'm not getting out of myself
there we are preview we started that
transition in 2010 and six years later
we finally finished our transition out
of the data center and now we're
completely cloud-based
so you may say it's really great Dave
but I have a question well I'm glad you
asked how does Netflix think about
DevOps
well then the truth is we don't you
might say Dave this is a DevOps
conference the word DevOps is literally
in the name of the conference so I've
told you we don't think about DevOps
take a few things we do think about we
don't build systems that say no to our
developers and engineers there is no
push schedule there are no push windows
there is no crucible to production
people have to go through in order to
have their code blessed so that it can
go out into the production world
engineers at Netflix would never see
that second half of the screen every
engineer and really everyone at networks
and Netflix has full access to our
production environment there's nothing
there to tell them no we don't take the
time to build systems or have policies
or procedures that prevent people from
accessing the production environment so
what do we think about we think about
freedom and responsibility one of the
goals at Netflix is that we want to hire
smart people and get out of their way if
I hire someone who's good at what they
do and they're intelligent they need to
have the freedom to make the decisions
to solve the problems in the way that
they see best and if we've created a lot
of artificial constraints and guardrails
trying to predict what it is need to do
it's done me no good to hire smart
people we also look for people that are
the kind of people that take
responsibility they don't wait for it to
be given to them freedom and
responsibility is imbalance so you look
for people that enjoy that freedom and
exercise that freedom and understand the
responsibility that comes along with
making those decisions and taking that
kind of responsibility we don't think
about uptime at all costs now if you've
ever looked at Twitter when Netflix is
down some people think they're going to
die
so wanted to let you know we've checked
nobody ever has now there are some
companies or organizations for which
uptime that all costs is very important
yeah things in healthcare IT finance
those kinds of areas down time has a
different kind of repercussion not so in
Netflix we don't look for uptime at all
costs so what do we do we prized the
velocity of innovation I want those
smart engineers that I've hired to use
their freedom to develop new things and
new features and new ways of exercising
the system and new ways of delighting
our customers and Netflix as an
organization knows that we are going to
trade some amount of uptime to keep that
velocity of innovation I am proud to say
our uptime frankly is rather good but it
is not our first priority our first
priority is keeping our engineers doing
fun and interesting and exciting things
for those millions of customers
worldwide we don't do a lot of processes
and procedures as I mentioned earlier
it's it's difficult to have a
fast-moving organization full of people
solving new and interesting problems and
assuming that someone can build the
guardrails that are appropriate to what
they're going to be doing can think of
all the processes necessary that will
keep them safe in the decisions that
they're making it's really a very
bureaucratic way of thinking of things
bureaucracies have a certain function
and one of the primary functions of a
bureaucracy is to be able to take that
bureaucratic machine plug in virtually
any cog and get the output that the
bureaucracy wants the cogs are only
allowed to do certain things
it's very prescriptive lots of
guardrails a lot of processes a lot of
procedures so that any cog can fit in
and get the job done that's not what
we're doing we work very hard to look
for the right kind of people that aren't
a bureaucratic machine member we want
them to challenge the things that we
currently do we want them to have new
ideas we want them to try things and if
we try to contain them too much that's
not going to happen so what do we do we
trust the people that we hire that's why
we don't have
about allowing anyone into production
now when I mentioned that to some people
there's always this well anybody get
into production you know they'll just
shut everything down that's happened
precisely zero times to us in all the
years the production has been open to
literally everybody at Netflix we don't
do control you may have kind of gotten
that idea so far what we do talk about
is context I have the privilege of being
able to hire or beyond being on the
hiring crew for some managers that we
bring into Netflix people looking to
help you know help engineers do their
jobs and one of things I talked about is
that managing it Netflix is very
different than it is a lot of other
organizations in many organizations the
job of the manager is to determine what
needs to be done figure it out lay it
out and put their cogs to work it's not
true at Netflix the job the primary job
of a manager at Netflix is to make sure
the people they work with have a quality
and constant flow of context about the
business does it ordinary decisions
being made in other departments where
other people are going and what they're
doing so the people they work with can
make well-informed decisions exercise
their freedom well and keep moving and
doing things so we prefer context over
control we don't do a lot of required
standards we don't have a thou shalt
write in this language and use these
libraries and this framework in this IDE
Netflix has we have a lot of we have a
lot of jvm languages running around we
have job running around we have scholars
running around we have some closure
running around we also have Ruby and
Python running around we have rust and
go running around we have a lot of node
running around so we don't have these
required standards what we focus on is
enabling so as a as a for instance the
the teams that are responsible for your
interaction and the UI if you access
Netflix from a laptop or a desktop
something through a browser decided a
couple of years ago that they were
making Herculean efforts to write their
back-end in Java and the front-end in
JavaScript said you know we think we'd
really get we'd really get some time
back and we'd be able to exercise some
new advantage
and do some new things if we ran our
infrastructure on node instead of Java
they did not have to go through a
research process they did not go through
an approval process they did not have to
run a crucible to make that decision
they decided as a team that this was the
best thing to do for the company and
they rewrote the portion of the system
that they're responsible for and
launched it note it's the same when we
think about tooling I mentioned earlier
at Netflix there are tens of operations
engineers that run this whole thing
currently the operations engineering
organization Netflix is about 70 people
interestingly enough the vast majority
of those people are software engineers
what they do is they focus on writing
tools and enabling other software
developers to do their job and focus on
the things that they're good at focusing
and if we hire someone to work in our
billing group because they're really
good at writing billing and processing
code for billing should they have to
learn a whole lot about time-series
metrics databases should they have to
learn about the interesting and twisted
path that it takes to get things running
in the Amazon Web Services environment
no we want them riding willing go and
they literally would be what we hired
them for so we work and focus on
enabling our developers to be able to do
exactly that
spend the time on the things that we've
hired them to do we want to do silos we
don't do wells we don't do fences I was
rather impressed in my first two months
at Netflix I spent time just running
around can you tell I'm with tiny bitten
gregarious and just rocking over other
teams ago so what do you guys do and I
was impressed that they take the time to
tell me what their team did how they fit
into the ecosystem and even more so how
they worked with the other teams their
dependents and their dependencies in the
effects that they had on them and how
they work together I thought it was
gonna have to go to each one and try to
piece it together myself and here were
these people that are used to talking to
each other across teams doing it for me
we also have some of those traditional
operational senses you know the
operational engineering group does not
sit behind a fence over which code is
thrown and hopes that it will show up in
production
so we don't have any fences to throw
things over what we do is we focus on
making ownership easy I think probably
everyone by now is for the view build it
you run it we focus on you build it you
run it but with that enablement idea
again it's one thing to say you know
you're gonna you're gonna run your code
you're gonna deploy your code you're
gonna figure out the operating system or
gonna figure out your instances you're
going to figure out all of your agas you
cluster settings and all your Yale B's
and then you leave that thing out in
production it'll be fine because that's
be fine to the light you're getting
paged best of luck see later so we do
you build it you run it with a focus on
enablement making those kinds of things
easy so for instance we have we have a
fun tool called spinnaker by the way I
mentioned some of our tools vastly all
of these we've open sourced you can find
it at Netflix github di'ja spinnaker is
one of those and spinnaker makes it easy
for a developer to get there I term
their job putting the Appy thing in the
cloudy thing for some reason they don't
find that nearly as humorous but we want
to make that easy
so spinnaker allows them to describe a
little pipeline that says I want my code
from here to live in these places and
I'd like to have these kinds of things
run like the smoke Trust has to pass I'd
like it to run through the automated
canary analysis system and look for any
kind of performance regression so they
just do that quick description and then
all they have to do is publish their
code to a repository and the system
handles that for them from there
if the code smells funny if it doesn't
pass tests if there's some issue with
the way that it's being built out
that'll never make it into production it
passes all of its tests it shows up
exactly where it's supposed to traffic
is managed and now our eighty one and a
half million global customers are now
talking to that new code base so we
focus on making ownership easy we don't
do a whole lot of guesses and get
indistinct and we try not to fall victim
to to the the traditional thinking of
well that's the way we've always done it
we do focus on data Netflix is an
enormous data company I mentioned
earlier those two and a half billion
time-series metrics that's only our
operational data that's not accounting
for all the data we have to run all
those algorithms that we talked about
there's no financial data that's another
reality
a lot of the decisions really the vast
majority that Netflix makes are based on
data so a few examples when Netflix
started streaming in 2007
Jenny buddy around streaming Netflix in
2007 horrible catalogue at the time I'm
sorry about that so we started streaming
from our data centers in 2007 in 2008
there was a fire in one of the data
centers now for those of you that aren't
familiar fires and data centers very
incompatible so we had a decision to
make you know we're releasing space from
someone you decided well delete and we
start doing around datacenters we have
some really bright people I'm sure we
could find a way to do data centers and
data center management really really
really well but what we concluded is
that if our job is to win those moments
of truth being a really really really
good data center operator didn't really
help us do that so that's we made the
decision to move to the cloud we look
for partners that can do what we call
undifferentiated heavy lifting work that
needs to be done but for which having it
done doesn't bring our customers in a
direct benefit there's some people out
there on the vendor floor today that
Netflix uses their services because we'd
much rather have them do it and build it
and let us use it so we decided to move
to the cloud in 2010 we've done our
first bit of streaming 2 devices out
there in the world from amazon's cloud
and by sometime in late 2015 we finally
finished our transition from the data
center to the cloud for those of you bad
at math that's a long time making that
transition is hard but we finally made
it other times in which data is helpful
we do a lot of looking and digging at
what people watch and what they enjoy
and what they come back and watch again
and the related kinds of things they
watch so we were able to produce there
was house of cards up there earlier that
was a very data-driven decision we had a
really good idea about the kind of
stories people like the kind of actors
they would enjoy the kind of director
that would bring that story to life
and we took a gamble and we produced it
and honestly it's been one of our
biggest success stories ever
so everything Netflix does
is driven on data now one thing that we
don't do mentioned earlier we don't have
a knock or anything named like a knock
this is a this is a picture of the
Operations Group at our headquarters in
Los Gatos
you may notice one thing here that's
different than a lot of other
organizations in their Operations Group
we aren't surrounded by televisions
showing us graphs we're a data-driven
company decision driven company we have
two and a half billion x series metrics
if I took a 15 inch MacBook Pro with a
Retina screen and I stacked up 90 of
them I could almost get one pixel for
every time series that we have who's
gonna stare at that interesting
experiment I suppose we also believe
that human beings are entirely too
intelligent and frankly entirely too
expensive to spend time staring at a
screen hoping they'll pick out a problem
out of a complex system so we invest in
data and we invest in algorithms and we
invest in systems that can comb over all
of that data very very quickly and let
us know when there's a problem and we
leave that charge in the organization by
this example there aren't TVs with
screens and graphs and sounds early I
can tell you the person taking the
picture it's not like they're behind him
we weren't trying to be succeeded so we
are data driven operationally yeah and
this I work on the team that is
responsible for you press play and it
works or if it doesn't work that's our
work environment we're data driven as
well so as I said we don't do DevOps
what we do is focus on our culture I've
mentioned a few words and phrases that
are important in the Netflix culture and
that we bandy about and we talk about
things like freedom and responsibility
context over control even in our hiring
process if somebody's going to come in
and see if Netflix is a good fit for
them the first thing we always tell them
to do is to go through our culture deck
and make sure that the way you do things
and the way you think about things
or we think about things is compatible
with the way you think about things
there have been some people I've had the
privilege to interview that were
brilliant but they would not have
benefit in our culture at all and we
value our culture and its benefits so
highly that we will pass on people that
would have a negative impact on our
culture so the result of the Netflix
culture really looks a lot like DevOps
but the important thing is the focus
DevOps is a wonderful result of the
healthy culture and healthy thinking if
you have problems you can't just hope to
take the DevOps cream and rub them all
other things and all of your problems
will go away surprisingly doesn't work
that way now other people have said this
to me not you of course it sounds very
nice Dave but it won't work where I work
and I'm always curious so I have to ask
some questions or really why doesn't
this thinking or this methodology work
and invariably I end up making some
blunt statement like this you don't have
a DevOps problem you have a culture
problem if you want the benefit of
DevOps or whatever work whatever the new
phrase will be for this change in
mentality for the way that we did I team
engineering over the years you'd have to
address your culture just giving people
that ops titles won't fix the problem if
you're curious about that that slide
deck that talks about some more of these
things is about 127 slides right now I
think that's you can find that at jobs
at Netflix calm now I'll go through all
the points of the culture and all the
things that we value well I'm glad you
asked there's a lot of information about
people we'd like to have come play with
us at jobs Netflix con have a couple of
cohorts with me Brian and Blake are here
with me from Netflix we're hanging out
at our table out there now we're a
little different than some other people
you may traditionally sleep conferences
we don't have anything to sell you the
first you know a month of the service is
free to you and literally billions of
other people
all the software we make we give away at
github but we do have some really nice
swag that we like to share with people
and we love answering questions and
talking about what we do how we do
things and why we enjoy it so much so
please combine channels I'm Dave Han I'm
a senior sre on the port team at Netflix
that's where you can find me out on the
Internet's so our call centers exist in
two pieces the question was how much of
this culture exists in our call centers
and I'll let I'll let Brian holler at me
since he knows this information a bit
better than I do we currently have I
believe 21 call centers around the world
close enough these not connect me we're
21 call centers around the world 19 of
those are actually outsourced to
business partners so the culture there
is dictated by what the business partner
the business partner believes is most
advantageous we have recently opened to
Netflix branded and owned customer
service centers one in Utah and one in
Yokohama Japan that will start doing
more and more of our customer service
work and our culture is just as
important there as it is in Los Cabos
sure so the question is how does this
whole freedom and responsibility you
know set of set of verbs deal with
things like PCI audits we do have a
small segmented area inside of Amazon
where we do all of our payment
processing and if you want access to it
you just have to go ask so still rather
compatible within reasons so that audits
are reasonable but not still it still
still under the same you know still
under the same flag we run all the same
tools all of those kinds of things any
other questions
there one of here yes how does our
culture affect our interview process did
I hear that correctly I like this
question so part of our interview panel
we have people in our talent team that
actually specialize in feeling out
whether or not someone is a culture fit
so that's always tested because we
really don't like that I do that we
bring somebody in and we hire them and
we change their lives just to go sorry
so it's a very important part we also
have a very free-flowing
back environment you are expected if you
work at Netflix to give people feedback
all the time to the point to where
people come pull it out of you if you're
not providing it we do the same thing in
our interview processes and I've said to
people doing interviews you know I like
you a lot you're great engineer but you
don't want this job so very much so even
during the interview process very
important because if we're gonna bring
them in they have to be able to work
with people like me so I'll answer the
second one first cuz that's easier I
mentioned that we're kind of
free-flowing on languages and the
questions was how are things like
templating standards enforced they're
handled team by team that team is
responsible for that that you build it
you wanted idea there are teams that
have developed everything from coding
standards to template standards to
things that work well for that team but
they're not pushed throughout the rest
of the organization so it's a team by
team question then your other one was
need to pizza three pizza Amazon kind of
thing I'm not familiar with that one at
all so if you can tell me what you mean
I'd be happy to answer otherwise I eat
so sounds great yes - please okay so the
average team size at Netflix last I
counted was 11 now we do have those
teams grouped together for instance the
operations engineering team I mentioned
is 70 people that's working up amongst I
think right now six teams so maybe not
intentionally the same but very much the
same kind of model we don't have large
teams let's see I think Jason's gonna
push me off the stage so I will be back
at the Netflix table happy to answer
more questions if you like intelligent
answers Brian and Blake will be there as
well thank you all so much
[Applause]
are you doing